- [Instructor] Let's
say that we are trying
to understand a relationship
in a classroom of 200 students
between the amount of time
studied and the percent correct.
What we could do is we
could set up some buckets
of time studied and some
buckets of percent correct
and then we could survey the students
and/or look at the data
from the scores on the test.
And then we can place
students in these buckets.
So what you see right over
here, this is a two-way table.
And you can also view this
as a joint distribution
along these two dimensions.
So one way to read this is that 20
out of the 200 total students got
between a 60 and 79% on the test
and studied between 21 and 40 minutes.
So there's all sorts of interesting things
that we could try to glean from this,
but what we're going
to focus on this video
is two more types of distributions
other than the joint distribution
that we see in this data.
One type is a marginal distribution.
And a marginal distribution
is just focusing
on one of these dimensions.
And one way to think about
it is you can determine it
by looking at the margin.
So, for example, if you wanted
to figure out the marginal distribution
of the percent correct,
what you could do is look
at the total of these rows.
So these counts right over here
give you the marginal distribution
of the percent correct.
40 out of the 200 got
between 80 and a hundred.
60 out of the 200 got between
60 and 79, so on and so forth.
Now, a marginal distribution
could be represented
as counts or as percentages.
So if you represent it as percentages,
you would divide each of
these counts by the total,
which is 200.
So 40 over 200, that would be 20%.
60 out of 200, that would be 30%.
70 out of 200, that would be 35%.
20 out of 200 is 10%.
And 10 out of 200 is 5%.
So this right over here
in terms of percentages
gives you the marginal
distribution of the percent correct
based on these buckets.
So you can say 10% got
between a 20 and a 39.
Now, you could also think
about marginal
distributions the other way.
You could think about
the marginal distribution
for the time studied in the class.
Then you would look at these
counts right over here.
You would say a total
of 14 students studied
between zero and 20 minutes.
You're not thinking about
the percent correct anymore.
A total of 30 studied
between 21 and 40 minutes.
And likewise, you could
write these as percentages.
This would be 7%.
This would be 15%.
This would be 43%.
And this would be 35% right over there.
Now, another idea that
you might sometimes see
when people are trying
to interpret a joint
distribution like this
or get more information or
more realizations from it
is to think about something known
as a conditional distribution.
Conditional distribution.
And this is the
distribution of one variable
given something true
about the other variable.
So, for example, an example
of a conditional distribution
would be the distribution
of percent correct
given that students
study between, let's
say, 41 and 60 minutes.
Between 41
and 60 minutes.
Well, to think about that,
you would first look at your condition.
Okay, let's look at the students
who have studied between
41 and 60 minutes.
That would be this column right over here.
And then that column,
the information in it,
can give you your
conditional distribution.
Now, an important thing to realize
is a marginal distribution
can be represented
as counts for the various
buckets or percentages,
while the standard practice
for conditional distribution
is to think in terms of percentages.
So the conditional distribution
of the percent correct
given that students study
between 41 and 60 minutes,
it would look something like this.
Let me get a little bit more space.
So if we set up the various
categories, 80 to 100,
60 to 79, 40 to 59,
continue it over here, 20 to 39,
and zero to 19,
what we'd wanna do is
calculate the percentage
that fall into each of these buckets given
that we're studying
between 41 and 60 minutes.
So this first one, 80 to a hundred,
it would be 16 out of the 86 students.
So we would write 16 out of 86,
which is equal to 16 divided by 86
is equal to, I'll just
round to one decimal place.
It's roughly 18.6%.
18.6.
Approximately equal to 18.6%.
And then to get the full
conditional distribution,
we would keep doing that.
We would figure out the percentage.
60 to 79, that would 30 out of 86.
30 out of 86, whatever percentage that is,
and so on and so forth
in order to get that entire distribution.